the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
today we're going to talk about
vibrations topic of vibration isolation
which is a very practical use of knowing
a little bit about vibration so imagine
you've probably been in a situation
you've been in where there's an air
conditioner in a window and it's causing
your table to shake or where you're
trying to work or your bed rattles or
something like that how many of you have
ever had an experience like that
something's kind of annoying messing up
a lab experiment or whatever yeah you've
all experienced these things right so
what can you know can we as as clever
engineers are there simple solutions
sometimes to fixing these problems and
that's what we're going to that's we're
going to talk about today I have a
little quick demo that I'm going to show
you you saw this the other the other day
or this is my little squiggle pen and
it's got a rotating mass inside and
we've looked at rotating masses a lot so
it has some unbalanced statically
unbalanced rotating mass could be a fan
blade with a hunk of chewing gum or
something stuck on a blade or broken
piece out of it puts in a four semi
Omega squared cosine Omega T basically
an F naught cosine Omega T kind of
excitation and if it happens to be a
flexibly mounted mass spring dashpot
system it'll vibrate so I showed you
that the other day we'll do this and
we'll need to lower the lights a little
but today I have set your bed here this
is your microscope here a little one you
can see it in foreground and this is
your air conditioner or the water pump
or whatever it's causing the trouble so
this is running about 28 Hertz is what
if I set this strobe just right I can
absolutely stop the motion it doesn't
look like it's moving at all that's
because the strobe is at exactly the
same rate as the squiggle pen now I'm
going to detune the strobe a little bit
so you can see the motion there's the
motion of this main system that's the
process causing the problem but it
actually puts the vibration into the
tabletop a next door over here I have a
little beam and you can just see that
little piece of white moving up and down
it's just a little flat piece of spring
steel with a magnet on the end as a mass
and a piece of white tape so you can see
it but notice it's going up and down in
synchrony with the other one so this is
some this is your microscope sitting on
a lab bench some distance away the
problem vibrations being created by the
original imbalance in something travels
through the floor gets to your table
with the microscope on it now your
microscope shakes so what can we the
issue is what can we do about it
okay oh I do yeah and we'll leave this
for a second I'll turn it off and then
I'm going to have you consider so I want
you to you know get in pairs and talk
about this I want as a group we're going
to come up with at least three ways to
reduce the vibration of your microscope
relatively simple ways to fix it how
would you do it
figure give me so think about it talk
about it and come up with three ways of
fixing this problem
I'm going to do one more demo on this in
a minute and then put up the transfer
function for the force the one we had
the other day okay a picture
all right let's have some suggestions
how would you go about fixing this
all right so put it put some Springs on
what the spring support the microscope
all right so I have this blue this
little magnet here sitting on this beam
this is that spring supported microscope
but I've done a heck of a lousy job this
thing shakes like crazy so what do you
mean not like that how am i okay so if
you think that you could change the
properties of this system so that it
might do better let's think about that
okay what's another idea
yeah if you change the length are you
talking about the microscope one the
receiving one if you change the length
of it it change it make it longer it
makes it softer actually make it shorter
it makes it stiffer so you would change
its natural frequency that's that now
the two ideas together you if you set
the natural frequency correctly you can
actually make that says the second the
system on the receiving end you can
reduce its vibration and I will
demonstrate that in a second what's
another idea after damping okay well
that's a very interesting suggestion
damping it helped under one circumstance
but not under some others we're going to
explore that today what so but we
Stella's is all basically we've come up
with one of the three ideas what else oh
that's interesting that's the fourth one
I mean that that can be a little
expensive but these are like noise
cancelling mic headsets right could we
put in something else somewhere else on
the table that cancels the vibration at
where you're trying to wear your
microscope is yeah you could do that a
little expensive what else yeah where
would you put that yeah and so that's
generally the same idea so you're all
treating the microscope it can you treat
something else in the system so yeah
we'll fix the microscope end but that
might knock it down by a factor of 10 I
want to knock it bound by at least a
factor of 100 if not a factor of a
thousand ah you know put another piece
of gum on the other blade or tail or
clean it up or balance the rotor in
effect rotors are not manufactured
defective usually they get rejected at
the under at the quote QC before it goes
out the door so fix the rotor can be a
little expensive sometimes but worth it
you know they do maintenance checks
actually they have accelerometers
built-in to all expensive rotating
equipment these days it's called
condition monitoring and when they get
outside of certain limits
shut the thing down and rebuild it
electric generator sets gas turbines jet
engines on all aircraft are all
incredibly carefully balancing they
start getting out of balance they stop
and fix them before the things blow up
on them and you have a 20 million dollar
problem instead of maybe if $20,000
teardown alright so yeah if you fix the
rotor third idea
well could you this thing shaking like
crazy what if you put it what if you
change the length of this beam would it
could you stop this thing from shaking
so much if you stop this I'm shaking so
much what it puts so much excitation
into the table no so treat fix the rotor
isolate the source isolate the receiver
now you get at least three ways and the
gentleman up here came up with a fourth
way active cancellation okay great so
let's I have a demo of one of these
sometimes if you're desperate you're
trying to get some sleep in onto your
bed that's rattling or something you
might want to try the following that you
can do very quickly so we'll dim the
lights again we'll turn it back on both
of these things are both are vibrating
like crazy alright so one way to detune
the receiver is to put a big weight on
it and change its natural frequency by
changing the mass and now the little
thing is hardly shaking at all because
I've detuned it just by switch it's
changing the mass accomplish the same
thing as change switching the length
instead of messing with the stiffness
I've changed the massive system this is
still shaking like crazy okay so now
it's back to vibrating again but over
here is my source I don't know if it'll
work so well in this one because this is
that the source is a lot more massive
but I need to put the same mass on it
but made it worse
ah and that's another good demonstration
excellent so we could come up back up
with the lights you got to be careful of
that you go to mess with one of these
systems if you do it wrong you make the
matter worse first consulting job ever
had back in 1977 or something like that
they had a vibration problem on a ship
and the first consultant in said stiffen
up it was actually the exhaust stacks on
these 5,000 horsepower diesel engines
and they were 30 feet tall and shaking
like crazy and the first guy said
stiffen up those exhaust stacks and he
did exactly the wrong thing and it just
shook like worse than ever
okay so now what what I'm going to show
you will put on the board today is a
little bit of mathematics to back up how
you go about doing the two things one is
isolating the receiver or the other ones
isolating the source it will start going
to start with isolating the receiver but
we're going to start with a little bit
of math a little math tool that we need
that'll make life a lot easier for us
maybe I'll work here if you recall last
time that would be the time to do it we
derived the transfer function for a
essentially this system where we had an
F naught cosine Omega T and we computed
the response X of T at some X naught
cosine Omega T - a phase angle and we
worked it all down to where we could
plot it like that but you know quite
frankly I mean I'd it was kind of a lot
of lines of math and it was sort of
painful I actually hated doing it on the
board but it was easy because it was
familiar it's just trig stuff it was all
trig and a little bit of calculus and so
we do that first because it all makes
sense to you mathematically but there's
a vastly easier and quicker way to do
this which we'll address right now and
that's using complex numbers and the so
we'll we need a couple of bits of
information here one is Euler's formula
so if you have e raised to the power I
theta you can show that that is the same
thing as cosine theta plus I sine of
theta that breaks into a real part and
an imaginary part okay so we wanted to
express this excitation F naught cosine
Omega T in complex notation we would say
it is the real part which I denote as re
the real part of F naught e to the I
Omega T and I'm going to dispense Phi
that F naught itself here this is real
and positive
so this this is real and positive so the
real part is going to be f naught x and
if you break down code e to the I Omega
T into its by Euler's formula it gives
you cosine Omega T plus I sine Omega T
and the real part is the cosine part
just according to this okay now another
little fact that I want to show you is
if you have a complex number A plus bi I
want to express it as sum c e to the I
theta you want to use Euler's formula to
express a complex number and if we draw
it the answer becomes pretty obvious
this is a point up here a bi this is
imaginary axis here and the real and
this point this side is a and this side
here is B and this side here the length
of this triangle is C and the angle in
here is Theta so now if I ask you what's
C we say oh well C is obviously the
square root of a squared plus B squared
and theta is a tangent inverse of B over
a which is the imaginary part over the
real part
okay so now you can set if you want to
express a complex number this way well
the magnitude is square root of a
squared plus B squared and the phase
angle that you put up here is tangent
inverse of the imaginary part over the
real okay so now we have the basic tools
we need to take on the vibration problem
and so we have that system up there and
our output from the way we derived it
last time the output is some X naught
cosine Omega t minus fee
one of the reasons it was so painful
doing it this way last time is you have
to this is cosine as a functionable time
and phase and to break it apart takes a
lot of work so we want to do the same
thing but with complex variables this
time so I want to express this then as
the real part of I could say it's the
real part of X naught e to the I Omega t
minus V and just by Euler's formula if
this is real just a number then this
breaks down into cosine Omega t minus V
and I sine Omega T mine
minus V but here's the beauty of using
complex notation and Exponential's this
now becomes the real part of X naught e
to the minus I P times e to the I Omega
T I can separate these two and this is
what makes it so much easier to use this
approach and I'm going to call
this part of it just some capital X and
it is a complex number for sure I break
this up into cosine V cosine of minus V
and minus I sine V it's got an IEEE sign
fees this got this is a complex number a
+ bi kind of form so in general this
thing is complex so this whole thing is
the real part of some X which I don't
know now e to the I Omega T so now we
can quickly quite quickly do this the
derivation we did last time we're
talking about representing linear
systems by some kind of black box as a
transfer function in it which we call H
in this case X F response X per unit
input F remember we're talking about
steady state response only and we have
as our input here some F naught e to the
I Omega T and we have as an output some
X e to the I Omega T we know that we're
going to use the convention that we care
about this is we have to have real
answers real number answers so we'll be
using eventually to be actually using
the real part of the input and the real
part of the output but to get there
we're going to use complex notation
first and separate out the real and
imaginary parts at the end
so for our system it we know the
equation of motion so now it's some F
naught e to the I Omega T there's our
equation of motion and I'm going to let
X here be this unknown capital X e to
the I Omega T and I'm going to plug it
in and the Exponential's are
particularly easy to deal with when
you're taking derivatives so upon doing
that we immediately get minus Omega
squared M plus I Omega C plus K all of
that times X e to the I Omega T equals F
naught e to the I Omega T and right
immediately I can get rid of the
time-dependent parts and I can solve for
x over F which is what we went out we'll
set out to do the other day to find this
transfer function between input and
output
so I'm if I solve for X divided by F I'm
going to get all this stuff in the
denominator on one side and I'll write
it out here simply looks like that and
now remember I can substitute in some
things remember K over m is Omega N
squared and Zeta is C over 2 Omega n M I
plug those things in and just rearrange
it a little tiny bit well we come up we
should come up with something like we
found before so that x over F 1 over K
denominator 1 minus Omega squared over
Omega N squared
not quite yet here plus 2i Zeta Omega
over Omega n that's what it looks like
so you still have a complex denominator
and this basically looks like a number 1
over K times 1 over some a plus bi
there's a term it should be i-10
if I multiply and the way you deal with
something like this you have an A plus
bi in the denominator you multiply the
numerator and denominator by the complex
conjugate I want to get this into
actually standard a plus bi form
so I can if I do that symbolically here
it comes out looking like a minus bi
over a squared plus B squared that's 1
over K e to the minus I fee over a
square root of a squared plus B squared
because now see this is just a real
denominator is just a real number so
this whole thing is in some form c plus
a di account you could break this into a
real part complex part we could say
that's equal to some magnitude times a
eetu the I fee and the magnitude to get
the magnitude you multiply they you take
a squared plus b squared square root it
cancels this is this is squared the
denominator to end up with this part
square root in the denominator this is
what the we need to know what fee looks
like well feed better come out like
before we're now fee is minus tangent
inverse of the imaginary part over the
real part and the imaginary part has a
minus here that's why I minus pops up
here imaginary part comes from this the
real part comes from there
the common denominator stuff all cancels
out when you take the ratio
this is tangent inverse of 2 Zeta Omega
over Omega n all over 1 minus Omega
squared over Omega N squared as before
I've skipped a couple steps but we crank
this whole thing out before this is just
this is the same trap steps that you
would go through to do that we're just
doing this to get to the phase angle but
this now is exactly the same thing we
got before which we have plotted up
there we tend to work with the magnitude
we work with magnitude and phase angle
so the magnitude of X over F is the same
thing as saying the magnitude of the
transfer function and that transfer
function looks like 1 over K the
magnitude all divided by 1 minus Omega
squared over Omega N squared squared
plus 2 Zeta Omega over Omega N squared
square root that is the same transfer
function magnitude that we derived last
time with a lot more work and this
approach using complex variables you can
use for any input/output single-input
single-output linear system and we're
going to do it to derive right away the
transfer function for the response of
this to motion of the base
so if you follow how we use this complex
variables and e to the I Omega T's to
get here we can now apply the same tools
to do other transfer functions to be a
lot more efficient about it before I
jump to this one remind you how in
practice we use this so if the statement
magnitude of X over F equals everything
on the right there then in the way we
would normally use this is to say well
if you want the magnitude of the
response you take the magnitude of the
input force multiply it by the magnitude
of the transfer function evaluated at
the correct frequency that would give
you the magnitude if you want the time
dependence X of T well it's the
magnitude of the force magnitude of the
transfer function times the real part of
e to the I Omega t minus V and this gets
us back to when you work this out this
is your X naught and this is your cosine
Omega t minus V
so once you know what the excitation
force is and its frequency
put the force in here you valuate that
thing on the left at the correct
frequency write out the answer directly
and one of the homeworks for today we
just had just the question just had you
go through the exercise of figuring this
out at three different frequency ratios
like 1/2 1 & 3 or something like that
would put you to the left of the peak at
1/2 on the peak at 1 and way off to the
right out at the right edge at 3 and
you'll get three different response
amplitudes and three different phase
angles that go with it all right so
that's the review did the same thing a
different way and I'm going to move on
to base motion but any questions about
this now yeah yes
the very top expression up there we want
it says x over F and says we're trying
to cast it in e to the minus IP form
that's my goal and I did that because we
started over here with the problem that
we had done before where that's the way
we decided to write the answer and it
turns out that it's just a convention in
vibration and vibration engineering that
authors and people have adopted to
express the phase angle as minus fee it
could have done it as plus fee but so
when you and you plot the plots like
this our fee oh I see you mean it is
it's in it's in there before you take
its magnitude so the hxf when it is
this here is left in complex notation
and this is this is H X F of Omega and
it is it's complex we take its magnitude
in it be then the magnitude is not
complex right and so we take its
magnitude we get that expression but
when we take its magnitude we've thrown
away the phase information so we have to
keep it and put it somewhere and so we
put it in a the e to the I fee form and
I guess I what I could have done here is
now this is I've taken this is H X F
same thing as x over F in complex form
and I've chose said ok if I write it
this way I have just said it is a
magnitude times its phase information
I've separated its phase information
from its magnitude by writing it this
way okay and the phase then is that and
its magnitude is that good question all
right
so now let's see if we can kind of
pretty quickly do the same problem for
base motion so this is our microscope
now idealizes a mass spring system
so this is our microscope has some mass
stiffness damping motion X of T and how
do you suppose that and where do you
where would you measure that motion X of
T from have to define your coordinate
here just there's a major point in the
last known work it's gravity involved
but only as a constant term mg and the
equation of motion it's only there if
you depending on how you if you write
the equation of motion in the less
desirable way where is this measured
from do you guess equilibrium position
static equilibrium position or zero
spring force position how many suggest
zero spring force position how many
suggests static equilibrium okay you got
the message this is static this is from
equilibrium because you know you don't
deal with the mg term so this is from
measured from equilibrium
that's the deflection of the microscope
support this is the deflection of the
floor that's driving it we know we've
got that table shaking like crazy that's
what's causing this to vibrate and we
need a Freebody diagram and we approach
Freebody diagrams just like before you
imagine positive motions of X and X dot
positive motions of Y and y dot and
deduce their forces so a positive x
gives you a KX opposing a positive X dot
gives you a CX dot opposing a positive Y
gives you what the force the results on
this positive motion of the floor
positive or negative force how many
think positive how many think negative
we aren't sure how many aren't awake
okay look if I push up on this and now
this is fixed when you do this mental
experiment you fix this momentarily you
cause a positive deflection here it
compresses the spring there's a spring
push back or not so if I'm moving
upwards which way is a spring pushing
all right so the but if I'm pushing
upwards which way is the spring pushing
on the mass up so this one gives me a KY
up and the dashpot does a similar thing
see y dot up and there's also an mg here
but there's also a K X static if you
will up and they cancel we know that so
we don't have to deal with the mg terms
so now we can write our equation of
motion in the equation of motion for
this system is the mass times the
acceleration has got to equal to the sum
of all the external forces one two three
four of them and I'll just to save a
little time and board space I'll put
them in the on the correct sides of the
equation so this these are the X put the
X terms on the left side CX dot plus KX
and on the right hand side I get KY plus
CY dot
this is my excitation that's the floor
motion and this is my response on the
left-hand side so I'm going to let Y of
T the input be some Y not real positive
times e to the I Omega T and I'm going
to assume that the response is some X
probably complex e to the I Omega T so
this is X of T here equals some X I
don't know e to the I Omega T and I'm
going to plug those two into this
equation
I just do that directly X is on the left
side y is on the right side then I find
minus Omega squared M plus I Omega C
plus K like before X e to the I Omega T
equals K plus I Omega C why not e to the
I Omega T and nicely I can for now throw
away get rid of the time dependent part
and I can solve for response that I'm
looking for x over the input its real
and positive amplitude of vibration of
the floor and that I will call H x over
Y of Omega a transfer function probably
complex that I can then deal with like I
did above and when I finish manipulating
things putting in substituting in Zetas
and Omega n squares and that kind of
thing this becomes well first of all
write it this way I can write this as a
magnitude times an e to the minus I fee
again that's what I'm trying that's
where I want to go
and when I do that one plus little
Messier to Zeta Omega over Omega N
squared square root this is just the
numerator and the denominator
denominator is just the same as the
other single degree freedom things 1
minus Omega squared over Omega N squared
squared plus 2 Zeta Omega over Omega N
squared square root of e to the minus i
fee so now it's the same it's the same
transfer function as before except the
denominator is a little little messy and
there's no 1 over K and I am going to
have a Messier expression for feet here
so there is something wrong with one of
the boards this morning
kind of messy complicated do I ever use
it rarely provide some of what's
important in these things and what isn't
really what's important when you're just
trying to get a quick solution to
vibration isolate something you really
want to know what this going to come out
looking like you're trying to make the
response X small compared to the input
that's the whole objective right now you
know the table might be moving a half a
millimeter or something like that but
this thing's moving out here you know
five or six or seven millimeters so IRA
ten times that what we'd really like is
if the tables move in a millimeter you'd
like this thing out here move in a tenth
of a millimeter and so the real
objective here is to make this small
it's the magnitude you care about phase
you rarely even it really even need to
know you want to know or need to know so
we're going to do a sample calculation
into an example here so the source is at
20 Hertz so you're unbalanced pump and
balanced rotor yeah the same like ah
what's like why wouldn't it be like
twice that okay that's a great question
I haven't mentioned this before and I
and intended to these systems that we're
looking at our linear systems what's the
where we started the other day linear
systems have some interesting property
and very useful properties that we
depend upon one was I said you know one
force gives you force one gives you
output one force two gives you output to
force one plus two gives you up to some
of the outputs the other feature of a
linear system is steady state
response after the transience of died
away if the frequency of the input is at
21.5 Hertz the frequency the output is
at 21.5 Hertz period linear systems the
frequency of the input is equal to the
frequency the output that's a really
important little factoid to remember so
I turn on the pump the pumps running at
20 Hertz 20 Hertz times 60 is 1200 1200
rpm very common motor speed so the pumps
mounted at 20 Hertz so that fan it's got
an imbalance so that means you're
putting excitation into the floor at 20
Hertz and I want to reduce the vibration
at the microscope by 90% what that
really means is I my goal is that the
magnitude of x over Y is 0.1 that's the
magnitude of this transfer function H Oh
x over y so I want this transfer
function to be 0.1 so just look at the
picture can I get that answer to the
left of the peak now what this plot
shows you is this magnitude of the
transfer function for a variety of
values of damping of course the lower
the damping the higher the peak gets at
resonance right so no matter what the
damping is what is the curves all go to
on the left-hand side they go to 1 and
that's really saying the static response
of this system is if you deflect the
floor an inch the table moves with it
everything goes everything has to move
together when you get down
to zero frequency input so everything
goes to one on the left you go through
resonance at natural mega equals the
natural frequency but on out to the
right as the excitation frequency gets
higher than the natural frequency the
response drops off below one which one
drops the fastest which as you increase
Omega over mega and beyond one which
Kurt which each of those the whole mess
occurs to the right that blend together
then they differ only in damping can you
tell which one is the let's say if you
go to at three there the response is at
about 0.14 the lowest curve on that
curve right and that's the one with no
damping little counterintuitive right
all right well come back damping does
help but not heat not at this point so
we we need to find a value of Omega over
Omega n which is greater than one that
satisfies this
that's what we're after and this is kind
of messy to work with the easy and I
sense I know the one that works the best
is the one with no damping
we'll just so we'll solve the no damping
one first which makes the algebra really
easy and then we can go back and say now
what happens if you add some damping so
for the case there's no damping the
numerator goes to one the denominator
goes to just 1 over 1 minus Omega
squared over Omega N squared so it
becomes that that's simple and because I
want to work with number this is ratio
bigger than 1 I don't want this to be
negative and I want to mess with keep
carrying along absolute value signs this
is the same thing as 1 over Omega
squared over Omega N squared minus 1
I just reverse this because I know we're
going to deal only with ones greater
than 1 here and I need this to be equal
to 0.1 and that's just algebra you can
solve that this implies that Omega over
Omega N equals root 11 I recall
and that is 3.31
so this is saying on that curve if you
go out to Omega over Omega N equals
three point three one right about where
that arrow is that the curve for zero
damping drops down to zero point one and
now if at that frequency so we need that
means we have to design the spring
support such that Omega n is equal to
Omega over three point three one but
Omega where do we start
so F equals 20 Hertz Omega equals two pi
F do I have that number here no but so
this tells me that I need a natural
frequency that is omega over three point
three one or I need an F and that is F
over three point three one is twenty
Hertz
over three point three one and that
number I do have six point zero four
Hertz so I need a support whose natural
frequency is twenty Hertz divided by
this ratio by three point three one and
that's I need a support is natural
frequency is six point zero four Hertz
and that's how you go about designing a
flexible base to isolate something from
vibration of whatever it's sitting on
alright let's so my F here twenty Hertz
well my F n needs to be six point zero
four Hertz that implies x to pi
I'm looking for 37 point ninety six
radians per second and that's equal to
square root of K over m so now what's
the M well it's whatever the mass of the
microscope plus its base
whatever your whatever is being
supported by the springs the will have
that mass you have to choose the K so
let's say let say the M total for this
system is 20 kilograms solve this
equation for K and that implies that K
is twenty eight thousand eight hundred
and twenty-seven Newton's per meter so
if we were designed this system and it
really mounts up to in the case of this
let's see beams is this stiffness of a
beam wow that's a good we'll do this we
have a little we have a cantilever here
and we've got a mass on the end but you
most of you have been taken to double O
one if you put a force out here P what's
the deflection at the end of a
cantilever okay so Delta PL cubed over
three e I and the load this force is
equal to some K equivalent times Delta
right this is just a spring and K times
the displacement is the force it takes
to do it
so P is my force the Pring constant is
somehow associated with the rest of this
stuff so if I solve for P over Delta I
get three
I over L cubed okay so if if my if I'm
running right at the natural frequency
here and I want to reduce this to a
tenth of its motion I need to change the
spring constant of the cantilever by
factor of what I need to change the
natural frequency by a factor of three
point three one so my K equivalent here
is 3e I over L cubed and that's what
would go into this equation but I know
that I have a I have a natural frequency
right now I want it to go down by a
factor of three point three one so that
means I need to decrease K by the such
that the square root of K goes down by
the factor three point three one so how
do how much do I have to change the
length probably something like the
square root of three point three one
roughly two if I double the length of
this thing you think it's going to work
I double the length of this thing and
turn it back on we shouldn't see much
motion out of this that's moving a lot
Oh a tiny tiny bit it works so that's
one step of vibration isolation now I'm
going to show you a vibration engineer
trick which is very handy thing to know
where's my strong magnet here so I've
got another beam just like this one and
a pretty pretty massive magnet on it so
it makes another cantilever beam just
like I got over there okay so I claim
that with just a ruler if I clamp this
down and at some length I claim with
just a ruler I can predict the natural
frequency of that take a couple minutes
and see if you figure out how to do it
think about that just a ruler
measurements that I can make I don't
just I don't know how long it don't know
how long it actually is I don't know I
think it is it's I know it's steel but
you just don't have enough information
to compute L q 3i over L cubed but with
simply with a ruler I'm going to be able
to do this talk about it think about
that well I set up D set up the
experiment
okay who's got it figured out we want to
take a shot at this
so there's my beam I put the weight on
it what does the beam do statically
bends a little right K X static equals
mg right has two so X static is when I
call it Delta here so K Delta equals mg
K equals mg over Delta natural frequency
equals square root K over m
credibly simple huh so what's the
experiment that I would what what
measurement would I make Delta right put
my ruler up there I measure its static
position like that and I put my mass on
it and I measure the static position
again I measure the Delta and I get a
prediction and I did this in my in my
office
and the Delta that I measured so the
length is actually set it at a
particular length it was 18 centimeters
Delta measured thick 0.5 centimeters or
0.0 0.0 5 meters and if you compute
Omega n then equals the square root of
nine point eight one over 0.05
and I want this in Hertz I am divided by
2pi this comes out as 7.0 five Hertz and
FN measured was six point five seven
pretty good but not perfect
what and it's because it made an
approximation I glossed over pretty
quickly what has been left out of this
system that would cause the measured
natural frequency to be lower than the
predicted what's been ignored yes
damping ah maybe how much damping do we
have in this system probably at least
ten cycles the decay halfway right
certainly less than one percent so
natural is the damped natural frequency
is equal to the natural frequency the
square root of 1 minus Zeta squared so
this is something like way less than
half a percent difference so that
wouldn't account for it that's
considerably more than half a percent so
damping couldn't do it yeah ah the mass
of the bar does this flexure have mass
yeah it's probably the order of you've
stack them all up and compared to that
it's probably you I might even be as
much as half the mass at the end and as
it vibrates back and forth does it have
kinetic energy yeah we've ignored the
kinetic energy of the mass and in fact
that's the principle error here we've
left out the mass it's actually pretty
simple way to account using energy just
thinking in launch terms you can account
for the energy of the mass in this
single degree freedom system and get a
very accurate position of a prediction
we won't do that today but it will do
that before the terms out
okay this applies to any simple
mass-spring system in the presence of
gravity so here's a mass and actually
I'm we're doing the problem today where
I'm moving the base here so here's its
base so hisses this is the table moving
and if I do this it clearly makes that
move if I do this really fast it doesn't
know very much if I do a close-up
natural frequency it moves a lot if I
move it very slowly as I go up one unit
this it follows me exactly that's why
that plot goes to one at very very low
frequency the support and the mass move
exactly together at high very high
frequency if I can stop the transient
can't do it very well the mass doesn't
move much the basement lives a lot and
at resonance it goes nuts
okay the unstretched length of this
spring is about seven inches the square
root of G over Delta I ought to be able
to predict this so I did a quick
calculation on that and I came I had we
did it it was like one percent error I
measured it it's seven point three six
radians a second and I'm predicted at
four point seven four seven point four
three measured seven point three six
same kind of thing ignoring the mass of
the spring a little bit so G over Delta
is a great little thing to remember okay
so we have done all but one everything
we started out with today we said
there's three ways to fix this and came
up with the fourth way so in this case
soften the spring support a lot so that
the natural frequency is way less than
the excitation we said we could what
about spring supporting softening
flexibly mounting this source so that it
doesn't put vibration to the table
that's the piece we haven't addressed so
let's look into that problem now
so here's our source some rotating mass
eccentricity causing an excitation so
this has a force F naught e to the I
Omega T which is coming from the
rotating mass and it applies to the
floor through the dashpot in the springs
some ft I'll call it F transmitted to
the floor e to the I Omega T and I want
to know I need the H force transmitted
per unit force input transfer function
that's what I'm looking for
so now Freebody diagram now we're going
to make an assumption we're going to
assume that the motion of the floor
which we'll call Y of T assume that Y is
much much less than X it's generally
true whatever is doing is shaking like
crazy before the tables not moving much
underneath it so I would assume for the
purposes of calculating forces that this
is zero so for the motion X what is the
force applied to the floor so f of T if
you have a positive displacement X the
force is KX you have a positive velocity
X the force pulling up on the floor
through the dashpot is CX dot so the
other way of saying that is here's our
free body diagram here's our F naught e
to the I Omega T pulling up it responds
at some X and the resulting forces
through the spring of the dashpot we
know are KX and CX dot opposing the
motion acts well by third law if these
are the forces on the spring and the
dashpot then down here on the floor you
better have some equal and opposite
forces KX and CX dot so motion this
force produces a motion X the motion X
produces forces in the mass in the
spring which make this the floor the
force on the floor the spring force and
the dashpot force okay
so this ft is right here
that's all that is positive and I'm
going to assume a solution we know to
work for X which is X e to the I Omega
key we plugged it in before so if I plug
that in here I get a ke plus I Omega C X
e to the I Omega T so I can just express
my force on the floor in terms of the
motion X
and I'm looking for a transfer function
for force transmitted over force in but
force transmitted is my ka plus I Omega
C X e to the I Omega T and the force in
is F naught e to the I Omega T cancel
out the time dependent part and it says
the transmitted force over the input
force is this little complex expression
times the response x over F but we know
what that is that's the transfer
function HX F so this is K plus I Omega
C times H X F of Omega so this gives us
a slightly different transfer function
and have I proved look at this
before when we did x over Y we ended up
with K plus I Omega C Y e to the I Omega
T and we did when we did then X over Y
we got the same same ratio as this
exactly the same thing so I could write
all this out but and let's say I'll do
this H X over Y no I don't do that well
it turns out what I'm going to tell you
if you just work through this now you
will find that H force transmitted over
force in is exactly the same as H X over
Y
and that what we really care about is
what the magnitude is so the magnitude
of these two things are the same and in
fact just work out to that same
expression as before the 1 plus 2 Zeta
Omega over Omega N squared square root
all over the usual but denominator so
conveniently for vibration isolation the
two the solution to the two problems are
exactly the same so if you have that one
you have the transfer function XY that
was projected on the screen a minute ago
it is also the force transmitted to
force in transfer function so you just
have to get you have to remember one and
if you will now want to we said let's
say doubling the length of this just
about accomplish the reducing the
vibration of the microscope by this
factor of ten so if I doubled the length
of this one I would have come I would
roughly do the same thing I would change
that I would make the change in natural
this thing is right on the natural
frequency this beam that's why it shakes
so much and it's Trent it's so it is
this system it's shaking like crazy
putting force into the table the table
is vibrating putting causing the other
one to move so now if I change this one
and the same kind of idea maybe roughly
double its length natural frequency
diminishes by a factor of three or so
the vibration of this ought to go way
down
and actually a little beam out here is
picking up more than the other one so
this is hardly moving at all in so by
doing that we've essentially detuned it
this is no longer running at the natural
frequency of this base so it's no longer
resonant you're way out on the curve to
the right so the response of this isn't
very much that means it doesn't transmit
much force to the base maybe down by a
factor of eight or ten it means the
table vibration amplitude drops by that
factor means that the base motion over
here is now a factor of ten smaller than
was to begin with so that we get a
reduction of ten here and we get another
reduction of ten here because we detuned
it so you might get a factor of a
hundred reduction by working on both you
so you've treated the source and you've
treated the receiver but fortunately
they use the same curve now so damping
when you do vibration isolation you're
trying to get well out on this curve to
the right so there's a couple of
practical engineering things that limit
how far you can go to get further out in
the curve to the right what do you have
to do to this spring of in the system to
get stronger or softer you're trying to
make the natural frequency the
excitation frequency doesn't change in
order to get omega over Omega n to go
bigger and bigger the excitation staying
the same every to reduce the natural
frequency and so what do you have to do
to spring constant decrease it what is
the practical limit of decreasing the
spring that supports your pump or your
washing machine or your air conditioner
pretty soon it's just going to if it's
to hit put it on they're just going to
squash the springs right so you can't
there's limits to how soft you can make
Springs just support heavy machines so
there is a practical limit to how far to
the right you can go but you normally
you get out there as far as you can
and then if you the real system has
damping does it improve or degrade the
performance of your vibration isolation
system well the more the damping you
have the higher up you are on those
curves so the damping decreases the
performance but every system has to when
you first turn on that motor the system
has to spin up and you're going to have
to go through that residence so you want
some damping because if you this is if
you've got your scanning electron
microscope or your laser interferometry
system set up on a on a spring supported
table if that table has no damping and
you walk in the door and bump it it is
going to sit there and vibrate all
afternoon at its natural frequency due
to the initial condition so you need
some damping to prevent problems either
response to initial conditions or
bumping it or whatever or even as the
system turns on and speeds up it'll have
to go through that resonance and it'll
vibrate like crazy as it does and then
finally settle down at it's at the
higher frequency so you need some
damping but damping does degrade the
steady-state performance and I'm out of
time and we'll see you in recitation
thanks